welcome to face off i am your host cabot
phillips
today is the time for us to answer a
very important question and that is
which daily wire host has the most
knowledge of quotes from famous dead
guys and here to help us answer those
two very important questions are the man
himself mr michael knowles best-selling
author host of the michael knowles show
michael welcome thank you for having me
on my own show cabot you remind me each
time we do this that this is in fact
your show i'm not the host but just let
me believe just for a little bit and
your competitor today in the face-off
competition is mr ben shapiro who's i
might add his best-selling books
do actually have words in them ben
thanks for joining us
you bet this is only a lose-lose for me
i also will point out that it might be a
lose-lose for you michael has yet to
lose any of these competitions he bested
matt walsh in showing who was the best
daily wire catholic the better catholic
is of course
matt walsh
but knowles got more answers right all
right and he bested dave rubin and who
is the greatest culture warrior you know
michael is a man who's very comfortable
with his sexuality
michael is coming in on a hot streak
this is a great point cabot because you
would say right now my lost board is
clean naturally it's clean and when you
want to clean all of your services i
would recommend that you check out
naturally it's clean more from them
later first though
i have got to try to keep up my perfect
win streak
i am now up i'm up against the big boss
this is not you know i love dave and i
love matt this is
this is going to be maybe a little more
formidable
formidable indeed
so let's just get right to it so you
don't get any more nervous that i'm sure
you already already are
this is face off famous dead guys
the rules of the game are simple i will
read a quote from a famous dead man
you two will have 30 seconds i'm sure it
won't take 30 you'll have your answers
in quicker to answer who said that quote
which famous dead man was it
then we will get right to it the first
quote for you gentlemen today
i disapprove of what you say
but i will defend to the death your
right to say it
i disapprove of what you say but i will
defend
to the death you're right
oh actually hold on there's like there's
more of a story with this one i think
there are two correct answers that we
will take for this one because there is
a little bit of dispute
on who exactly this belongs to
all right michael you're finished ben
we'll start with you because you got
yours in first
supposedly voltaire
michael who you going with so i'm i i
put the little second caveat one down
there but i did put voltaire up first
it's a little tricky when you name
voltaire these days because a gop
congressman just got
in trouble for confusing a quote from a
neo-nazi pedophile with a quote from
voltaire but i'll stick with the first
one supposedly voltaire you were both
correct we would have accepted voltaire
or evelyn beatrice hall
uh there was uh some dispute still on
that probably getting misquoted by a lot
of people
not by you gentlemen
well done one point to each next up
by all means marry if you get a good
wife you'll become happy if you get a
bad one you'll become a philosopher
ben's got his in michael okay all right
michael
you're gonna go first on this one you
got i i guessed aristotle not because
i've i've heard aristotle say that or
read it but because all those old greeks
were gay guys and so i figured if they
had an unhappy marriage that would be
more likely for them
ben what about you uh yeah
i went with samuel johnson
mainly because it kind of sounds like
samuel johnson
uh michael was closer on this one this
one was actually socrates really
that is what the producers are telling
me so if not take it up with your
producers michael you think that was
incredible i almost wrote socrates but i
thought aristotle was the funnier gay
guy
joe but that wow okay do i get points
for that oh that was pretty close
even though it is your show we're not
going to deadly now what ah darn i
should have put socrates i would've been
funnier okay next up
with great power comes great
responsibility
ben's taking a little more time than you
so maybe maybe easy for you michael
ben we'll start with you walk us through
the thought process i saw some some deep
thinking going on well i mean it depends
where you are in the multiverse as to
who says this right
as uncle ben
says this to peter parker or
alternatively marissa tomei says it's
peter parker
all right very thorough michael what you
got i uh
i'm not as much of a nerd on this i i
just said spider-man i don't is does
that count
no that's incorrect i do not think we're
gonna get
because also i would just like to point
out at this point you're not a nerd for
enjoying the you know most popular movie
in the world michael you don't have to
play that game i'm just
oh
no
uh ben you get points for that we also
accepted uh uncle ben
uh winston churchill stan lee or the
apostle luke who said to whom much is
given much is expected
any of those we would have technically
taken spider-man
does not count unfortunately
all right fair enough next up
i can calculate the motion of heavenly
bodies but not the madness of people
all right michael we'll start with you
who you got
i'm shooting in the dark here
as was this man galileo
all right ben
i also said galileo but
i'm i'm with michael it could be like
three other guys i i want to say very
close
generally close it was sir isaac newton
newton yeah okay yeah
he was the other guy i was thinking yep
me too
all right so no points awarded there
next up
let my teaching fall like rain and my
words descend like dew like showers on
new grass like abundant rain on tender
plants
let my teaching fall like rain and my
words to send like dew do
ben is just rearing to hold up the
whiteboard so we're gonna go to him he
looks very confident
i'm gonna go with my boy moses all right
michael from deuteronomy oh darn i i
went i wanted it to be more mystical
so i suggested um
confucius
mr shapiro gets the points on this one
oh
devastation that's my book michael
michael yeah you're in my you're in my
backyard with that one brutal you know
i'm doing bible in a year i can almost
cite that one in the original hebrew i
can almost write that one in the
original event i always start bible in a
year and i and i've so i've read genesis
about a thousand times and uh but i'm
not i'm not yet up again to deuteronomy
i'm still on exodus
many a bible reading plan has died on
the shores of deuteronomy
next up no no it all falls apart in
leviticus deuteronomy is great
i actually may have gotten that wrong
next up
this one again this is a quote from
someone else
i am a deeply closeted gay guy
um
you can't say socrates again
i'll read it one more time for the sake
of reminding me i am a deeply closeted
gay guy
can't make the socrates joke you already
did that
man
i'm having i'm having a real tough time
with this one i'll be honest with you
ah
hmm
slightly more there's so many jokes and
i can't pick between them i can't pick
between them what what do we do
i don't know okay we'll do this would it
help if i read the quote one more time
no one more one word time gavin all
right fine all right michael who'd you
go with
ben might know how to quote moses
but i know how to quote
norm mcdonald
ben
oh i had rock hudson so
norm mcdonald was in fact i think a very
self-described deeply closeted gay man
i'm a deeply closeted gay man you're a
gay man i'm not gay
i said i'm deeply closeted point to mr
knowles so you're saying he was a gay
guy
well i said he ascribed himself to he's
a deeply classic closeted yes
i'm hoping our producers are keeping
score in my ear because i'm just kind of
throwing out points left and right next
up
i'm up three tube i'm not three too yeah
i think ben's up keep going of course
ben was counting
next up history repeats itself first as
tragedy second as farce
ben who you got
i had nietzsche but i think it's wrong
michael i believe it is marks and angles
and the reason i say marks end angles is
i think angles actually said it first
we've got karl marx so we are going to
give you the point on that
unless ben can make a compelling
argument otherwise
no i cannot i cannot make a compelling
argument that's that's okay all right
first time i've ever heard ben say that
that saddens me that i didn't get that
that is a blown opportunity
okay i mean in in fairness it just means
that you haven't been keeping up on your
marks which probably is is for the
betterment of your soul
he has been keeping up on his old
testament though which strips for the
betterment of his soul as well next up
more important yeah exactly our
constitution was made only for a moral
and religious people it is wholly
inadequate
to the government of any other
who we got
i'm going to say
that it is the man who
conservatives quote 50 000 times a day
with that exact line john adams
point to both of you well done there was
never any question there for either of
you there's no suspense i don't want to
build suspense where there is none no no
that was an easy one move on to the next
politics is the ability to foretell
quote some lock and null's in trouble
politics is the ability to foretell what
is going to happen tomorrow next week
next month and next year
and to have the ability afterwards to
explain why it didn't happen
a little more suspense here
ben what do you got yeah
i had churchill but this is another one
where i'm just not sure
i went with a different marks i went
with groucho marks on this one
that is incorrect but ben does get a
point it was churchill ah that's awful
i'm back in the red
if my eyes could show my soul
everyone would cry when they saw me
smile
again if my mother is watching this it's
not a cry for help that is a quote from
a famous dead guy
uh
michael we'll start with you
i'm going with uh the marquis de sade
you're
again there's one person who's gonna
laugh at that joke and that would happen
to be ben shapiro everyone that's it's
okay yeah
who do you got that's true um well
actually cleveland would have laughed at
that joke so
that's
okay
um and uh i have proust mainly because i
have not nor will i ever read
this was a little bit of a trick
question it was actually kurt cobain
oh kurt cobain got it so i was much
closer than you yeah
actually was that that maybe yeah
up for debate
on second thought yeah next up
to write well express yourself like the
common people but think like a wise man
michael you're so confident let's let
you go first obviously who does this
describe
donald trump
there's no question
next next one next question
ben what do you make of that and what
did you answer
i went with the his ancient equivalent
plato
ben was much closer it was actually
aristotle
we keep dancing around the old freaks i
know ah we keep dan yeah
wrong greeks man
i think uh donald trump would be very
flattered by that michael or maybe he
wouldn't be flattered
who knows we'll find out on twitter
uh one of the one of our producers came
up with a friendly reminder just now
that trump is not dead so
this you know you're forgetting the
premise of the game michael that's true
ineligible you're here that's a good
point that's a good point next up
petrobiden is eligible
next up
i cannot help it i want to be a good
catholic but i'm a hedonist
hmm
i will be very impressed no fair writing
martin luther michael i know
i can't i cannot help it i want to be a
good catholic but i am a hedonist
this is another shot in the dark
ben who we who we putting down here
well it's wrong but it's true
several popes in the middle ages
[Laughter]
several hey that's a that's certainly an
understatement that's certainly under
counting
michael
i put down
and this is just because he was a
hedonist and he gets quoted a lot
oscar wilde
i do appreciate both of your answers uh
we're putting the man who lived down by
the river mr chris farley
wow yeah i was not gonna get that and
they're really they're really testing
y'all's knowledge here wow yeah
i well i really like what this game is
out of the box i like that they're they
the producers chose quotes that that are
not in any way well known that's right
i'm glad they did that right that's
that's the best part is they just sort
of randomly opened books
and it was like they had a book on their
shelf and it was like chris farley's
autobiography yeah and then they just
picked a random sentence and they're
like okay we'll put this one out this is
a quote yeah
i would like to take credit for any
quotes you guys like and get correct and
any that you've never heard of that was
the producers they put those in and we
will move on
a man has free choice to the extent that
he is rational
are there repeats
there are not
you may offer repeat answers but there
are not repeat
correct answers
a man has free choice to the extent that
he is rational mr shapiro who said that
i'm gonna say descartes
knowles i wanted to go a little more old
school
i suggested saint thomas aquinas
very impressive michael knowles that is
correct hey all right
there are too many catholics on this
list this is not yeah
this is not okay that's it was one of
those one jew and many catholics you
know all of the enlightenment guys they
liked rational rationalism a lot too but
people forget those old school medieval
scholastics they liked their reason all
right so is this it's ty now
yes we are tied
oh man
it's intense okay i have high hopes for
both of you guys on this one
every man has a property in his own
person
this nobody has a right to but himself
sounds like some kind of like some kind
of like lib stuff
hold on
[Laughter]
this is definitely not saint thomas
aquinas uh
trying to see how many letters ben is
writing there
hmm
michael are you done
yeah like sure whatever i'm so divided
here let's hear it
i'm so divided i
lock i don't know i said is it lock
ben
i also said lock and you also are
correct you're both right john locke
oh man i was literally looking i was
like did ben write five letters
did he write five letters or only four
do you feel lucky punk well yeah exactly
exactly there was no luck that was all
skill
just like your skill michael at reading
some fantastic ads and i believe that
you have a great ad that we need to hear
about thank you very much that was a
pretty clean segue cabit and when you
want to clean all your countertops all
your surfaces all your carpets all
everything you have got to check out my
absolute favorite cleaning product ever
naturally it's clean
when you bring a product into your home
you want to be sure that your
hard-earned money is going to a brand
that believes in the same kind of
principles that you do you don't want it
going to a brand that hates your guts
we're talking about a brand that values
personal and environmental
responsibility
and more importantly your freedom which
is why i'm excited to share with you a
brand that not only has an incredible
cleaning product better than anything
else on the market but they also have
the same values we do that's naturally
it's clean it's a wonderful partner of
the daily wire naturally it's clean is a
home cleaning company dedicated to
providing effective cleaning products
using powerful plant-based enzymes
that's the key the plant-based enzymes
we're talking hospital grade cleaning
power here super duper safe it's it's
the sort of thing where you can bring it
in if you got kids and pets you don't
need to be worried about them you know
crawling on a floor that's that's used
this kind of cleaning product you can
use it on your floor and your carpets
everywhere i really recommend starting
with the daily wire four pack of the
essentials it includes four great
products visit naturally it's clean.com
michael use promo code michael to
receive 15 off your order cleaning
products are expensive if you keep a
clean home you're gonna go through them
fast we encourage our listeners to keep
a clean home and support companies like
naturally it's clean while you do it
they support your conservative values
check them out today get your daily wire
essentials kit at
naturallyitsclean.com
michael
one thing that's not clean are some of
these uh quotes that i have been given
to read
mainly this next one again these are not
my words
i love it when you call me big papa
i will add also that papa is p-o-p-p-a
if that is helpful at all yeah okay i
love it when you call me big papa this
sounds like right in my wheelhouse
right here
i think i'm ready all right ben let's
see who got
biggie
smoking blunts was a daily routine since
13 a chubby fella on the scene by the
name of
biggie smalls both very well done
gentlemen i would say
you guys know your music but i hold that
one
i did not expect to get that one right i
gotta be honest and you guys that is
well outside my wheels this is
impressive yep now ben is is is biggie a
musical artist or is he a a poet what
what do we consider him i assumed it was
his given name
that his mother he came out of his
mother and she said behold i shall call
him
moving on
iron sharpens iron so one man sharpens
another
michael who'd you put
uh
i don't know like shakespeare
i'm surprised by that one ben
i said john stewart mill ah that is
actually solomon king solomon king
solomon
oh i should have known that one well
that's i mean since shakespeare probably
wrote the kj they nailed you with
proverbs proverbs 2017 proverbs or 27-17
proverbs is so difficult to read man
michelle in hebrew it's michelle and it
is rough to read that it's like it has
so many great quotes but they're all
juxtaposed with one another in bizarre
order and so there's no through line so
everybody knows like three quotes from
proverbs but nobody actually knows how
they fit together because it's very yeah
proverbs is also one where i i guess i
could probably tell you a bunch of it
but i like i could never tell you like
to your point i can never tell you where
it is or like the numbers or really
anything it's all just kind of like a
yeah that's right
i smell a new show like an old testament
survey course taught by youtube
together oh yeah the ratings would be
through the roof that's what the kids
that's what the youths are after these
days
i would rather be stricken blind than to
live without expression of mind
i would rather be stricken blind than to
live without expression of mind
ben
keats because it rhymes
nols
uh i said shakespeare because it rhymes
and like one of these has to be
shakespeare right i mean a shakespeare
of the
20th century this was mr tupac shakur i
damn i almost wrote tupac as a joke
that's frustrating see this is this is
ben actually accidentally giving credit
to tupac for being a brilliant lyricist
yeah it is it is you know it is he he is
he is the modern-day keats that's that's
exactly right
next up you were not made to live like
brute beasts
but to pursue virtue and knowledge
we've got a standoff i think they're
both looking at the camera to see how
many letters are being written by the
other
michael who'd you put
okay uh
it's saint augustine i don't sounds kind
of augustinian i don't know ben
i also thought about augustine but we
actually have not hit plato yet right we
got aristotle correct but we haven't
actually gotten
yeah this was a tough one this was
actually dante
dante really
yes
oh you've read him in the original
italian that's why he didn't recognize
it yeah it's true yeah i don't i'm not
somebody who's in italian who had been
good if
you were not meant to live like would
you pursue virtue and knowledge i guess
i like vaguely yeah all right well
ah darn now i ah man i was really hoping
to have an advantage on the dante the
whole thing is like the seventh circle
of hell
do we have a we have a score update ben
are you still keeping score producers
what's the score right now no i lost it
a while ago i think i'm i think it's
even right now but yeah it is
yeah i don't know
seven to seven we've got a tie ball game
heading into this
final stretch and even for a while all
right none of us have gotten one right
in a long stretch here
next up
we must reject the idea that every time
a law is broken society is guilty rather
than the lawbreaker it is time to
restore the american precept that each
individual is accountable for his
actions
like four people i'm thinking of right
now
this was another tough one this was one
of the more uh
maybe unpopular of this person's
michael who'd you guessed no okay
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
he gave a clue he gave a clue he gave it
that's some bush yeah now he gave a clue
right there i thought the answers were
final
all right oh wait my conscience is clear
i can't do that either that guy's still
alive hold on hold on hold on here we go
oh i know who you were thinking for that
one
yeah you do don't you
[Music]
see you know it's um too i was thinking
of him too and i also forgot that he was
still alive yeah
how do you both know who the other is
talking about by being this vague we're
a little bit on a wavelength right here
cabot and that wavelength is hopping
over the center of this screen wait over
the center of that screen all right can
we do it now can we show the the yes you
can all right now i think what do you
have
i think it was reagan
ben
i had written reagan but then i changed
it to lbj because cabot suggested it was
surprising you always got to trust your
gut ben this was reagan yes
oh you you cheated me i literally wrote
ronaldo's maximus and then i erased it
because you wouldn't shut your face cap
never be led astray by the hosts
how can i lead you astray bless it
that's like wow
that was you said this was one of his
less popular stances are you kidding
that's what rod won ronald reagan the
presidency yeah
when you said it's one of those things
you're saying
i immediately assumed that it was
somebody of the last did you mean a less
popular quote though
a less popular quote where if people are
quoting ronald reagan typically yeah
that's not the one they're quoting like
when no
that's that's worse okay great anyway
all right continue the real reason i do
this is because michael is actually
three doors down from me ben you are
three states down from me so i'm more
scared of one than that
that's true now the difference is i
don't sign the paychecks so that
i may have miscalculated i told you this
is a lose-lose
michael and continue to sign him
paycheck and now sign a paycheck to a
corrupt host who's been bought off by
the sweater vest wearing jackass down
the hall from him
man this i was so gonna complain if ben
went from the wrong answer to the right
answer on that but now that's great
that's the way the rules work that's
fine okay we're good i was led astray
the proverbial cookie can go back
crumbled watch the tape go back and you
can see my hand move as i write run all
this maximus and then erase the answer
oh well okay i'm gonna move on before i
actually do get fired always do sober
what you said you would do drunk that
will keep that will teach you to keep
your mouth shut
always do sober what you said you would
do drunk
that will teach you to keep your mouth
shut and i'm going to keep my mouth shut
and not offer any clues
i really yeah i
looks like we got our answers in
hold on
ben i did not give him a clue he is
erasing this of his own will and
volition i know i know that was not that
wasn't you that wasn't you
okay all right all right
i'm so frustrated michael who do you
switch to so i initially i said george
burns because i could kind of picture
the quote with him smoking a cigar or
whatever but i changed it to chesterton
because i assume chesterton's going to
show up at some point since he produced
half of the quotes in the english
language ben
i said el capone
i wish i could give that half point this
was actually hemingway hemingway okay
that's fair enough
he never took the advice but yeah that's
good to know that he at least
well i mean he
he had no choice he was always drunk
that's true
so
he would no you never had to do anything
yep that's true next up is the shortest
quote of our list it is simply
he
he h-e-e what was it
h-e-e-h-e-e
he he like
i will read in different i'll read in a
different tone
he he's
that's it that's the quote could you
keep could you keep saying it cabot
um
i'm a little worried about more voices
what that might uh evoke in the comments
section so i'm not gonna do any more of
those but do we have any guesses ben
we'll start with you
the joker
joker
pretty close
i'm going to say
michael jackson it is mr michael jackson
yep
thank you i i didn't know at first but
the read really helped gavit i appeal
that one goes to the appellate court i'm
sorry that is the thing that the joker
also says
that is not
michael you won that but really everyone
lost for having to hear me say hehe
repeatedly that's true
the most effective way to destroy people
is to deny and obliterate their own
understanding of their history
ben is writing a paragraph over there i
got to see this ben what'd you put
nicole hannah jones and it's a playbook
not a
it's prescriptive actually
right actually yeah i
having never read
almost anything this man has written i
decided to say solzhenitsyn because i
could hear
jordan peterson quoting that as a quote
from solzhenitsyn
is this just you wanting to show to
everyone that you know how to spell
social needs that was a stab in the dark
too that was definitely probably some
vowels out of place this was actually
george orwell
orwell yeah okay oh fair enough
considering i had a book club on him
last month
the great part about about being a host
which i'm learning that you guys must
get to feel every day is the feeling of
superiority because i get to pretend
like i already knew the answer to all of
these things
when in reality the producers are just
telling me in my ear so
it's a nice feeling next quote lies
damned lies and statistics
they're not giving you guys a lot of
context here they're just giving you
those
five words i mean it's been quoted by
zillions of everyone yeah every human
yeah
michael
mark twain
and ben
yeah he's correct that's right i put
israeli but it is twain we've got mark
twain on here so michael will give you
another point there yeah disraeli though
i wonder if
israelis got some good quotes too that's
a that's a good one to throw in the
noggin if he if he might show up yeah
but
i'm i'm blowing this man this this
month's book is adventures of huck fitz
really
i'm blowing it yeah i'm completely
blowing it i'll admit that it's not in
huck finn though
okay brevity
michael's now running away with this
thing michael is running away he's got a
little bit of a lead here i didn't want
to give a score update because i didn't
want to appear to be rubbing it in but
yeah i wrote it or something it got
brutal here maybe ben i'll remind you of
what's at stake and this will motivate a
comeback you will have to film and
record a plug on your own show to listen
to michael's show
if you lose and vice versa so just a
reminder what's at stake
to be frank i do that pretty much every
day and it never helps so we'll just
keep doing it it never helps it always
hurts it always just digs right into
your okay well if you don't want to give
it to michael you can just plug morning
wire and that we'll call it even on that
and that's
what do you think i did this morning
all right anyway next up
brevity is the soul of wit
oh there we go michael it's all you man
you've been waiting for this one i've
been waiting for this one so it's kind
of it's kind of a trick yeah it's kind
of a trick question
why is that and explain your answer
let's see it michael well oh i actually
have to write down that like the real
one that i'm gonna get credit for okay
it's really you know everyone says it's
shakespeare but it's really
really polonius who says it his
character
in hamlet
[Music]
as
clearly neither of you are surprised
well done
next up
in individuals insanity is rare but in
groups parties nations
and epochs it is the rule
do we say epochs etbox epox what do we
what do we say there
i say epoch
that's what i but i don't know some say
two parts
yeah
exactly
do we have an answer can you read the
quote again read it again in individuals
insanity is rare but in groups parties
nations and epochs it is the rule
ben you've got a smile let's see it
well i mean i'm just going to crib off
of michael here and i'm going to say
soldier needs in this time
i i too said solzhenitsyn this time i
sort of thought it might be spengler but
then i thought it was like there's no
way they looked upstairs there's no way
they're quoting spangler no way or twin
b or something yeah no way this one was
nietzsche nietzsche i was like i i
thought it sounded too lucid to be
nietzsche should have gotten that should
have gotten out with myself now as soon
as you mention madness two out of three
shot it's a nietzsche yeah yeah it's
true it was just it was somewhat
understandable which is why i uh i
assumed there was no way it could be an
egypt but okay
ben you're gonna have to make a comeback
here you've got four quotes left to
mount
oh good seemingly insurmountable this
will be done
quote as the family goes so goes the
nation and so goes the whole world in
which we live
doesn't that sound nice
as the family goes so goes the nation
and so goes the whole world in which we
live
man i have heard this quote
this is incorrect but i'm just gonna
write it anyway because whatever man
it's over uh okay all right i'm just
gonna
it should have been this guy but it
isn't but michael we'll start with you
i'm i'm still stabbing at my
chesterton
it's not chesterton because it's not
like funny enough but ben
daniel patrick moynihan
this was pope john paul the second
pope john paul oh
yeah he was a good pope yeah i like that
yeah
this one
this well which one was the real
question
when they say this one people say which
one okay all right
i should have gotten that one
everyone thinks of changing the world
the family of animals is
this one's like the family of trees
is the foundation
i'll give you 30 seconds if you want the
floor just to bash the pope i mean
that's absolute that would be oh i mean
i think we're all on board with this no
you know how the catholics do it though
we always because you have to be
obedient so you're like well you know i
just think it might be like in a very
respectful you might be a preaching a
heresy papa francesco but you got to do
it like really nice you know
that's how it was it was almost
translated thomas translated everything
he says translated
every single thing he's actually
speaking french it's just well that's
the problem
yeah you can't get an italian right yeah
next up anyway everyone thinks of
changing the world but no one thinks of
changing himself
everyone thinks of changing the world
but no one thinks of changing himself
i was going to say michael jackson
quoting from man in the mirror but
there's no repeats
like
all right ben who do you who'd you go
with
i said cs lewis again wrong but it's
okay yeah i
i said gandhi
also probably wrong we've got tolstoy
here australia yeah that's definitely
um did tolstoy ever consider his own
advice or no did he yeah seriously i
don't know
it's like another hemingway type quote
okay
two more just for
you know the winner might be decided but
this is for prime so you could tie it up
this is going to be a bonus question we
might give double points for this one
because
i'll be very impressed okay just
hold on a second here we can easily
forgive a child who is afraid of the
dark just to rig this thing yeah the
real tragedy of life is when men are
afraid of the light
we can easily forgive a child who is
afraid of the dark the real tragedy of
life is when men are afraid of the light
um
i feel like this entire game was just
the entire book of bartlett's quotations
the entire book all 800 pages was the
length of this game
michael okay fine this time i'll do
chesterton i i do i'm gonna wait i did
lewis and my b suggestion was uh tolkien
the one time you didn't guess plato it
was played out it was plato i thought i
thought i kind of thought
okay
i guess that would kind of make sense
with plato
and we are down to our final question he
did love light yeah he did
our final question our final quote is
this
poor kids
are just as smart as white kids
and only dead people right
right i'll leave that up to the
producers who chose this
michael knowles one of the the true wits
and philosophers of our age
president brandon come on man
ben
joseph r mcbidenface
well done both of you well done i'm not
sure what qualifies as dead but
we now know that the daily wire host
who can quote the most
dead men accurately
is michael knowles michael would you
like to
how would you like to accept this i tell
you i have not been nervous about these
games before
but
i was go this is not this is not just
flattery this is not no false modesty
this is a man who knows a lot of dead
people but he there were some crucial
errors here and lapses in ben's
education namely michael jackson
and a handful of others as well so i am
i accept this with humility
and a great deal of joy
well you know all i can say is that
unlike naturally it's clean
this competition
was not in fact clean
and uh and i hereby challenge the vice
president of the united states mike
pence
to
overturn the results of this contest
and i believe that there will be a very
big rally a very big peacefully
congregate
near michael moles's office i i can hear
him peacefully i can protest at michael
knowles's office pardon's available
later i hear the door people are banging
on the doors i hear
facts don't care about your michael i
this is uh could be very scary
i'm just stuck in between what i'm
saying is
i'm with you
i'm i'm i'm with i'm with you're great
people you're all very good people very
special very special go on home you're
very great people you can go on home
unlike the vice president i don't have
the power to overturn
this competition unfortunately it's just
i've read the constitution thoroughly it
was not there i read the trivia bylaws
again it was not there i'm sorry i must
let this stand
but before i let this stand ben we're
gonna have you go ahead just off the top
i want it to come from the heart your
30-second pitch michael sit back and
enjoy right
if you wish to hear
a man
far too educated for his meager lot in
life
speak to you
of dead people
and their quotes then make sure to check
out the michael knowles show a
repository of other people's wisdom
and also a host who says things
sometimes
on that show you'll hear alleged humor
you will hear
verbiage in the form of english
sentences sometimes
and you'll hear
much
snobbery
there'll be a lot of talk about cigars
there there will be a
a bizarre sort of smarminess that you
can't seem to shake
but if you enjoy all of those things
then the michael moles show
is for you congratulations to the most
humble of our hosts
the most generous of spirit
the least corrupt
the the just a person i'm so glad to
employ
every single day
michael x knowles
thank you yeah that's that's that's all
thank you ben i'm honored i am going to
make that my new log line of the show i
think the michael knowles show a
suppository of knowledge that i uh thank
you that's awesome
we're going to leave it there before it
gets any weirder um i will say i'm
impressed that was well over 30 seconds
that's just been going above and beyond
very very kind of thing so generous and
charitable men and you are a generous
and charitable man michael for letting
me call myself a host on the show which
you host
i very much appreciate both of you for
joining the trivia challenge
and everyone for watching i'm kevin
phillips joined by mr michael knowles mr
ben shapiro thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]